I am running behind sorry everybody
I mean yeah sorry it's doing some
running around and lost track of time
and I'm not as organized as I should be
even with a lot more effort going into
trying to be high it should be evidenced
by the fact that there is no topic this
week as tribute to you know my my
inability to organize worth a dang
alright let me get this taken care of
over here do that ah yes good evening to
you as well we're toasting Merlot now
lovely alright let me get the discord up
since there's no topic I have no idea
what I've got to find on the discord in
terms of questions being asked or
whatnot but uh just in case let me get
that going huh
hope everyone's doing all right ah oh
hufflepuff from Scotland drinking water
so I got nothing to lose permission spam
the FAQ and get everyone we said a
permission denied permission did I dis
Pam permission granted to occasionally
drop one in if people are running dry
rest in peace Terrance dicks yes yeah
that was I mean like he he had a full
life it's always sad when someone goes
but you know I did
I am also host people who you know once
they hit a certain see if that comes
back sorry about that I to just decline
a call coming in cuz I'm a dufus who
still haven't figured out a better way
to do this than on my phone because the
webcam on my computer is garbage
you know the really funny thing is is
that and this happened last week too I
basically every time somebody mentions
Terrance dicks in the in the chat it
gets flagged for review then has to get
approved before anyone could see it
because again cuz it Flags the language
we only got week Australian lager
I didn't think they've made Australian
beers that were weak for shame kind of
surprised you didn't bring that up in
your Prisoner of Azkaban review how
horrible Ron was presented in the film
well the thing is um it's been so long
since I've read the books that in many
ways the movies have superseded my
predominant image of the Harry Potter
characters because ivory watched them
multiple times that I've only read the
books once so I am not until I actually
do a full reread of the books which I do
not have time for then I'm not really in
a position to properly judge how
characters were or weren't changed verse
versus their their book counterparts I
have a much better memory for what
events change but character alterations
I don't have a good memory for plus
there was that really good video done
which I forget the channel was on but
there was a really good video relatively
recently about the changes done to Ron's
character not you know by any single
massive thing with just the accumulation
of lots of small tweaks that basically
did it better than I could do anyway so
between realising that I'm not actually
in a position to be able to say much
anyways because of the knowledge base
I'm working with and somebody did it
better yeah it just seemed weird to
bring it up oh thank you very much John
new patron really enjoy all you do thank
you well thank you as well cheers to you
ravenclaw in North Carolina
Slytherin in the house whoa
don't don't ever let me do that again
good god what was that next is the
Goblet of Fire see it's funny so many
people like in the comments for the
Prisoner of Azkaban one we're like Oh
Goblet fires next great did I hurry
watching her a while I remember really
liking Goblet of Fire the movie version
so I don't know if there's something I'm
missing or if that ends up being another
case of the better you remember the more
recently you reread the book the more
the movie annoys you I get which again
read the books but it's been so dang
long which classic companions would you
have loved to see with the ninth doctor
even if it was just one story like
school reunion ace always in forever is
gonna be the answer to that question it
is the most correct answer to that
question ravenclaw from Miss Michigan
since the first Harry Potter website on
the Internet Oh old school Ravenclaw
nice hufflepuff in Australia I love that
has become a thing than the chat that
everyone just gives the where they're
from in their their Hogwarts house that
makes me very happy
did you see the Doctor Who's season 26
trailer with old ace I saw that it went
up I didn't actually watch it I meant to
and then I did something else I do yeah
I don't even know ravenclaw from England
so there I'm from New York New York is a
well I was gonna say New York's a good
place for slytherins except I'm not sure
same thing
I sure it's a good place for also the
Rings cos I was done with New York after
four years but well that's New York City
though see I need to remind myself when
someone says New York they don't
necessarily mean New York City they may
mean New York State and that is like
living in a different country one versus
the other
ravenclaw from Wales well thank you very
much Amanda spreading the love from over
the pond in Scotland oh very nice
thank you kindly I'd love to I'd love to
visit Scotland I've been to London um
didn't really go outside city limits on
that trip but I would love to visit
Scotland
I'd love to I'd love to check out
Ireland too to be honest ravenclaw from
Scotland Slytherin from Germany
hufflepuff from Michigan ravenclaw from
Kansas Gryffindor from Chicago ravenclaw
from LA man all over the place I love it
Oh
slender claw no fair enough like it's
like it's not so clear-cut for everybody
like I I I kind of make myself like pick
one
Danya because my own instinct is to
straddle the line so sometimes I kind of
force myself to go with one and
something like Hogwarts is kind of a
case although like let's be honest I am
much more Slytherin than I am anything
else
did you ever mention your I can never
say it's right over more anyhow in the
chat I have its Wampus who do you think
the doctor would rival with more
Professor Slughorn or madam Unni I think
the doctor would get along decently with
mad-eye moody and I think most
incarnations of the doctor would have a
lot of issues with Slughorn which non
Doctor Who villains do you think would
be a good doctor who villain oh oh so
that's an interesting question well I
mean somebody like Loki would be an
interesting villain for Doctor Who
someone who does not necessarily have an
agenda all the time but is just very
into getting in and messing things up
cuz it's fun which is I mean a little
bit like the meddling monk was to be
honest I kind of would like to see some
more chaotic characters get thrown at
the doctor since most of his villains
tend to end up being you know people
with master plans I suppose it's because
the doctor tends to
to be a little bit chaotic themselves so
maybe that's why we don't get that kind
of billing all that much I don't know
I've just got stream-of-consciousness
going on right now Ra's al Ghul ooh
that'd be a good one
I'd like to see Tim Curry as the master
that that would have been awesome
I mean I say would have been tickers
obviously still alive but you know with
his with his physical state he's
probably not in the best condition to do
it at this point you should check out
old doctors new monsters audio I've
heard of that one I'm actually working
on an audio now I got commissioned
through patreon to do the Eighth Doctor
adventures time war number one box set
which I've just finished listening to
yesterday just finished listening to the
first part of that yeah no spoilers for
how I think about that hmm
Oh Bailey that's that's not fair because
I'm gonna screw up the first part of
that second part of that I've heard
enough that I can do it well but huh
Ramanna dev'reaux to tread wound our of
rexicoricophalvitorius I know I messed
that up what do you think about the news
of ace coming back for season 26 of the
Doctor Who collection I think it's great
I wish he I wish they'd get her back on
the show I really really do I don't
think there's any reason not to I mean
other than there doesn't seem to be as
much of an interest in deliberately
tying in the classic era as there used
to be obviously that there was a lot of
that more explicitly under Davies
because we had k9 we had Sarah Jane we
had a little bit under Moffitt you know
we had the we had the nod to to the
Brigadier because they weren't able to
between his health and availability they
weren't able to schedule him for that
though they did get to have him on Sarah
Jane Adventures and we're early enough
in the chicken'll era that it's kind of
early to call but I feel like this show
has as it's gone gone along has been
willing to go
less and less back to classic who which
all know what him is a good thing
because you don't want the show to be
too navel-gazing just sort of dwelling
in its own history you want it to move
forward but on the other hand like
there's so much history like we can go
back a little more than we have how's
the book going it's going pretty well
Elizabeth I I actually have it out to to
some beta readers right now and I'm
starting to get feedback through that
it's my first time going through the
process of getting beta readers and I'll
end up getting more you know before I'm
done I didn't do that with with the last
book I did with skirting gender because
I really only wanted to work with it
editor and you know get a format that
worked because that was very much my
story and I very specific you know
intent for what I was trying to
communicate and I always figured that
was gonna have a more niche audience so
I wasn't necessarily worried about
appealing to as many people as possible
whereas the book that I'm working on now
the novel I want to have the broadest
possible appeal so the beta reading
process is is that's going on also still
working with the illustrator I've got
two completed illustrations working we
started going back and forth on the
third one so that's exciting I'm I'm
debating I'm debating doing a
crowdfunding because I initially thought
I'm not gonna do that I'm because I
crowdfunded for my last book basically
to pay for an editor because I couldn't
afford and I didn't think I would for
this one but then I started doing the
illustrations because I'm trying to
think if there's a short way to explain
this I crowdfunded and skirting gender
through Kickstarter now the thing with
Kickstarter is it is a platform that
people actually peruse in and of itself
so in addition to you putting the word
out you know through whatever means you
have in my case the YouTube channel
Twitter what-have-you um people do
actually browse through Kickstarter to
look for stuff and that's not
the case so much with other crowd
sourcing platforms so with Kickstarter
the disadvantage potentially depending
on what you're doing of it is that if
you don't hit your goal you don't get
anything you either hit your goal and
then whatever goes over or you get
nothing and now some people might ask
why would you ever do that in my case I
wanted to do that for skirting gender
because hiring a professional editor was
going to cost me a minimum amount of
money and I did not need money for
anything other than that so if I didn't
make the well you know once I accounted
for what Kickstarter is gonna take off
once I made about the fifteen hundred
bucks I needed to hire an editor if I
didn't make that there was no point in
me keeping you know if I only raised
five hundred there's no point in me
keeping that cuz again hire an editor
with that and then what am I gonna do
with this money so that was the reason I
went kick-started that time I'm
considering doing something like
IndieGoGo this time for the novel
because since I've got illustrations as
part of this I am now actually in a
situation where even if I don't hit a
set goal which would probably be
intended to cover I'm headed or and full
illustration for the thing yeah I it is
then every little bit helps because
whatever more money I can raise as more
illustrations that I can I can cover and
be sure get in the thing so I'm debate
I'm still debating that though we'll see
Bailey I saw the trailers this is for
the Doctor Who think I saw the trailer I
was confused what the deal is with ace
coming back was it exclusively with the
trailer well that trailer that there was
two things so far as I understand she's
she's coming back in big finish so she's
appearing in the audio and because she's
in that season of Doctor Who they used
her for the trailers for the release of
that season of clastic era so it was
kind of a one-two punch going on there
uh any recommendations for horror movies
oh dang it I lost it I had it and I lost
it
let me back up any recommendations for
horror movies for this year's Halloween
my favorite one tends to be stuff like
the haunting the thing alien and oculus
well when it comes to scary movies the
ones that I tend to recommend off the
top of my head if you haven't seen the
woman in black for a real gothic kind of
ghost story that's a real good one
I recommend that I'm quite fond of the
descent that's a bit of a more visceral
film the the scariest movie to me ever
is the 1978 version of invasion of the
body snatchers which i think is the one
of the most creepy paranoia inducing
things you will ever see so if you
haven't seen any of those consider them
my recommendations if the doctor was in
Star Wars and force-sensitive do you
think they turned the dark side um I
don't know because the thing is as much
as I'd like to Star Wars I always limit
myself to the movies and so I feel like
the expansions of how the darker light
side of the force work and in terms of
influencing people and where they leaned
was something that was dealt much more
broadly in all the Expanded Universe
material which is stuff I just I just
don't know so III honestly don't feel
properly equipped to answer that
question I mean III will always say that
I think one of the most screwed up Jedi
powers is the Jedi mind trick and it's
very weird to me that that's a light
side thing because you're basically
overriding someone's freewill and
apparently that's a light side power
like what is overdue review ending with
last Matt Smith episode sort of it'll
probably transform into take to Doctor
Who review as I review stuff that have
already seen cuz by that point even when
I overrun things that have already done
reviews for a lot of them will be years
old reviews and my opinions may have
changed so I'll probably still keep it
going after that I'm soon starting
University studying media I found out
one of my modules is representation in
media I feel that
a topic you've inspired me with and how
to explore it Oh
Thank You Bailey best of luck I hope I
hope you do better and university than I
did
ie I hope you actually graduate have you
seen a raise new lightsabers I mean not
since the d3 footage the d23 footage if
we got a better and more extended look
at him I haven't caught it yet I'm still
an odd about Dark Crystal it really
surprised my expectations and they were
high but it was amazing yeah yeah I got
to watch out rewatch some of it cuz Liz
is still catching up she's about halfway
through now I got to watch her squeeze
over hop I really oh so who's on the
pending you're worried okay so this is
if you've seen stranger things
season 3 this is Robin and normally I
have Steve from stranger things and this
is actually Liz's pendant she has Robin
I have Steve we actually traded off for
pride and we're sort of keeping the
opposite was because we actually both
love both characters so we we switched
off for a little bit is there somewhere
you would rather live the more you
current little live um I mean there are
places I'd like to you know like if I
could have a summer home somewhere where
like a vacation home somewhere I guess
but like I I do like where I live
there's logistical annoyances about
where I live but you know I grew up in
Vermont and I moved back here and I'm
happy to have done that I I do like it
here how do you feel about you and
McGregor reprising his role as obi-wan
Kenobi I'm fine with that yeah I mean he
was one of the more consistent things
about the prequels so yeah I am totally
good with that what's the deal with
American University my impression from
the Internet is that people largely
think it's a waste of time and money
what Bailey it really depends because
there there's a lot of different I mean
over here we generally say college you
know there are certain things that are
called universities but you know we call
it going to college over here so there's
a number of things going on the first is
there are multiple kinds of colleges you
have your your big prestigious private
colleges you know your Harvard's your
Yale's you know the really renowned
stuff you have your state colleges
that's where you get things like the
univers University of Vermont and you
know UMass you know you universe UC
Berkeley and things like that still
pretty solid stuff then you get your
community colleges which are smaller and
usually um you know have more simplified
programs but they'll still get you a
degree and then you have the for-profit
colleges which are things like
University of Phoenix and DeVry which
fairly large a number of them are scams
now in terms of the whole thing of
whether or not Courage's College is
currently a waste of money it it isn't
it isn't the the thing is is that the
job market of the u.s. right now is such
that having a college degree now was
like having a high school degree thirty
years ago if you don't have it you're
going to be stuck in fairly low-level
mediocre work but there's a big
difference it's not just like it's
scaled up oh it's like having a high
school diploma because you can finish
high school without going tens of
thousands of hundreds of thousands of
dollars into debt which is what happens
when you go to college so the issue
we're having right now is given the
current job market how many jobs require
at least a two-year or a bachelor degree
to even get an entry-level position but
graduating college does not in any way
do that much to increase the likelihood
that you're going to get work in the
field that you studied and so you're
getting a job in one field while you've
got hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt hanging over you that
never goes away because college debt is
handled completely differently from
other kinds of debt the whole thing is
really screwed up right now and not
because of any one thing it's a
confluence of things between the
expectations of what jobs expect their
candidates to have in terms of hiring
combined with the cost of college having
gone up its yeah the there's a lot of
things have sort of piled on top of each
other to make it a very it's very
necessary yet at the same time if you
have a caused jury it is difficult to
pinpoint exactly how you have benefited
from the venture it's it's it's a
conundrum is what it is I'm getting
ranty on this one hold on I keep
skipping past what do you think the 10th
doctor would have done if he was on
earth during the four-five-six situation
or how would he react to Jack's our
sacrifices child ok this is a question
about Torchwood children of Earth see
the thing is I don't have an answer
because it's not a question I think is
that's worth exploring because the
reason children of Earth is as powerful
story as it is is because we don't have
an outside force we don't have a savior
this is humans having to deal with this
problem and the entire thing is
exploring how do we deal with a
situation this dire this destructive
what do we do and while I understand you
know there is still a question to be
asked what would the doctor have done
the simple fact is I have a hard time
answering that because at the end of the
day I don't care the very the very
premise undermines what makes that story
great and that's not me like belittling
saying that anyone's wasting their time
by engaging in that exercise just saying
that like I can't make my brain go there
because the very first turtle that I can
clear is what I even want to see that
the answer is no and then I can't
I can't I can't get there so there's
there's your insight into my brain
for this particular stream there'll be
more I am sure I think I might have
caught up on the nope here we go ah went
past it here we go
um I don't know if you watch the DC CW
shows but what are your thoughts on
Brandon Routh returning as Superman for
the crossover the only one that I watch
at this point is legends of tomorrow
which I'm not cut up on from the
previous seat seized and I'm about
halfway through it I'm enjoying it a lot
although I don't like Mona Mona's awful
but aside from her it's pretty good I
really like Charley
I really like what they've done with
Nate this season it's the best season
he's had I love Constantine as part of
the team
I love tomorrow a lot I mean I'm really
curious to see exactly what they're
doing I don't have an opinion in and of
itself about Brandon Routh returning to
play Superman again I thought he did
pretty well I think return of Superman
underrated is maybe a little too
generous
um it I see more value in it than a lot
of people do setting aside the issues of
the director but like just as a film I I
always saw more value in it than a lot
of other people including brain and
routs performance so like but in and of
itself that's like okay I don't know
enough about the context through which
it's going to be done so that's what I
would have more of opinion on sorry I'm
taking up the role again yeah sure I
mean why not its water
hahaha well not actually obviously this
time it's demonstrable not water it's
coffee
of a sort
when it comes to Eccleston's run of the
doctor if you were to create a situation
for him to have a Christmas special what
would it be oh I don't know I don't have
an idea off the top of my head for that
he never did that's true cuz he never
did get one first Christmas special was
tense for a story I mean I knew that but
I had to like really thought about it
that way don't suppose you watched the
Apple live stream if you did or their
own opinions you have on it worth
sharing or an Apple as a whole at the
moment um there was an Apple livestream
I'm not as plugged in to as much as as I
think people tend to assume just because
of the platform that I'm on I think
people think I am more tech savvy and
and tuned into technology in general
than I actually am have you read about
the interview Capaldi Gabe about the
writing of the show specifically Moffat
doing a lot of uncredited writing to
make up for the poor scripts written by
others I hadn't um read that interview
but I mean whether or not is because the
scripts are poor it's actually pretty
common practice for show runners to do a
lot of rewrites on scripts um and that's
not just specific to Doctor Who I mean
that you if you look behind the scenes
of any of the Joss Whedon shows he would
rewrite a great deal of the scripts that
were written by other people usually
modifying dialogue to make sure that
characters were speaking in the voices
that he wanted them to speak in so what
very showrunners tend to tinker with
varies I having not read the interview
I'm not gonna comment on whether or not
it was because the scripts weren't any
good I don't take that as a given just
because the showrunner was rewriting cuz
like I said that's actually kind of
standard practice because that's that's
half the purpose of a showrunner is to
ensure a consistency of tone and
characterization so whatever they have
to do to maintain
that usually involves you know rewriting
and tweaking but no I haven't read that
interview so I don't have any more any
more detailed thoughts on that bizarre
question but what's the weirdest thing
you like for example I'm a huge fan of
Pro Wrestling um I'm not sure there is
really anything like for a geeky guy my
the things I enjoy are I mean borderline
stereotypical um I don't know like I
would say archery but if you're gonna be
geeky guy and do anything athletic I
feel like archery or fencing or whatever
that's pretty much what lines up yeah is
it is it an actor an Akron is taking
useless yeah sure that's a geeky vaguely
sports thing um so no I don't know I I
wish I had an answer have you heard
about Peter Capaldi being cast in the
next Suicide Squad movie I did hear that
got brought up last time I have no
opinion cuz I have no idea oh he's
playing or how big his role is gonna be
I actually suspect he's not playing that
big apart because he was cast pretty
recently and the things been in you know
active development for a little while
usually someone's cast this late it's
not for a major role you know maybe if
you're lucky a pivotal role but not
something with a lot of screen time so
don't don't get your hopes up folks your
thoughts on a movie set in the Wizarding
World during the medieval times
I mean well then you just basically have
a Merlin movie wouldn't you I I don't I
don't think there's a lot to do that
because that's the kind of setting that
that kind of magic has almost always
been told in until things like Harry pop
I heard about em Diller Macworld overlap
with the more modern ish world is a big
part of the appeal of Harry Potter so I
feel like going back to medieval times
is undermining some of the core hook of
the whole thing favorite David Bowie um
me probably heroes I also have a soft
spot for Lazarus cuz I did that as a
performance piece as a as a burlesque
tribute so I'm partial to that as well
would you like Tom Baker to appear in
the next multi doctor story um uh I
don't know cuz I mean like at this point
if he was gonna appear it has to be as
the curator again which you know a big
part of why that worked and I did feel
it did was because we didn't know is
coming like maybe by voice I don't know
is there a Council of geeks discord I
don't know about there is silo but it is
a patreon exclusive perk so supporters
of the patreon are on it it's not open
to the public um I'm not sure I could
manage one that was open to the public
do you think Capaldi could be playing
Hugo Strange or scarecrow or am I being
too much of an optimist I don't know if
it's being an optimist I think you're
just spinning a lot out of virtually no
information I mean is it possible sure
do I think that's the case I don't know
oh thank you very much Carolyn I know
you've seen that number or video of it
at least
next multi-storey should be eight ten
eleven twelve thirteen and Patterson
Joseph um I would absolutely like to see
eight integrated into the next multi
doctor story that I would I do want to
see very much Capaldi said it was heavy
rewrites that made Moffat very stressed
and even said how underappreciated
Moffat was for the work he did behind
the scenes for no credit or pay huh I
might have to look this interview up I
think about he might be featured as
Alfred Pennyworth out of all characters
in Batman
Alfred's the only woman from the UK for
the most part well yes but they also
shaved his head Alvar it isn't well
known for that I don't think
well not in film I suppose he's been
bald and the comic sometimes but not
like in a shaved head way like in a male
pattern baldness way I look I I don't
know it's anything is possible a whole
think about he plays mr. freeze I mean
like who knows folks
what's the darkest thing the doctor has
ever done or the most out of character
ah darkest thing he's ever done I'm
probably stuff in the time war that I
haven't caught up yet cuz I'm still I'm
just really starting to dip my toes into
that through a big finish and whatnot um
it's not really out of character because
it's consistent with this specific
characterization of the doctor but like
Davison throws me off a lot the fifth
doctor he did he just he's so he shoots
somebody with a gun and he devises a
poison gas and he chokes a Cyberman on
gold dust like act like does these
things actively not sets them up and
then you know it's a situation where the
villains sort of cause order no he does
these things actively you shoot somebody
I Davison I have a lot of issues with
Davis and he just doesn't click for me
so I again I can't see he's out of
character for who he is being portrayed
as as the fifth doctor but the fifth
doctor to me just is fussing I just I I
don't I don't get it
I just don't I mean even the sixth
doctor I get now be thanks to Big Finish
they they found a way to make him work
but oh speaking of which uh-huh
I understand why you put Davidson's
doctor into Slytherin mm-hmm but I
disagree a little he's
level-headed cunning and he's quite
insecure I put him in Grif and in
Gryffindor
well he's not he's not level-headed but
he's like he the his actions are made
there maybe not planned far in advance
but he's not acting rashly like with the
exception of what happens an earth shock
when he takes out the cyber leader maybe
but the other ones I'm talking about
like in warriors of the deep or arc of
infinity he's not acting rashly he's not
making a snap emotional decision he's
making decision considering it and then
doing it you know you can make an
argument that it's not coming because he
didn't plan it that far in advance but
honestly ah does the prospect of Jim of
Chibnall doing the sixtieth make you
nervous and in it in any way depends on
what he thinks he's gonna do with it I
suppose any idea for any new hair colors
are you happy with it at the moment I'm
happy with the hair colors I have at the
moment because these colors fade very
nicely because I can't I
I don't do this myself and I can't
afford to have it done professionally on
any kind of regular basis so for me it's
important to have colors that fade
nicely so that it continues to look
decent as I continue to not get the
color refreshed so for that reason alone
I'll probably continue to to stick with
with these colors Gryffindor from Egypt
welcome who wants to live forever uh
that was a fun number to perform too as
well um actually I got a I got a hop
over to discord real quick give me a
second did you do to you um Papa Papa
here we go
[Music]
have you heard much about undone new
animated show from the Bojack horseman
folks I have not didn't even know they
were doing another one I know that there
was to convert e but that only don't
that only got one season I know about
that
see if there's anything else I'm gonna
grab do you enjoy crafting um I might
like if I had a better sense of what I
was good at like I've got very limited
craft materials and not a lot of
background or time to get good at any of
it I don't mind crafting I there are
times I can kind of get into the Zen of
it like I died sequined a bra for a
number a couple years back that you know
they kind of dug that but it's not I I
don't have crafts that I do on any kind
of regular basis or anything like that
uh how caught up are you on Brooklyn
nine-nine
I am multiple seasons behind on Brooklyn
nine-nine and so yeah that to my shame
do you think if we get a Shazam do you
think we will get a Shazam - and if so
do you think they should recast the
younger actors or have the characters
aged I still haven't seen images am so I
have no opinion I really uh that's
that's available to rent now I really
should get to that I like I've got my
day so packed with scheduling of
shooting and editing and I just I've got
so little wiggle room um you know to
even have a life or what passes for a
life if I sent you a flying muffin made
out of clay would you put it on your
shelf suppose it depends on how big it
ended up being and how much room it
would take if it wasn't too big I might
that said if it was just resting on my
shelf would it be flying
there's your philosophical question for
you Davis
then also doesn't violence he doesn't
hide when he gets grumpy with companions
any admits when he doesn't know what
he's doing that strikes me as unliving
well you know maybe yes as I get more
into Davison maybe I'll reassess but
from what I've seen I felt comfortable
in that and that assessment actually
staying the whole stream is gonna be
super easy barely any inconvenience oh
happy to have you up for the whole thing
about the size of a real muffin bat well
see I don't even know what to do that
cuz I I'm not sure where you're from
Andrew but where I'm from muffins come
in two sizes mini muffin and serious
muffin so if you're doing this like I
don't I don't really have room up there
for that you're gonna do a mini muffin
maybe we can work with that
Oh which of the marled Disney Plus shows
are you most excited for and did you
catch the announcement for moon night
she-hulk and MS Marvel I did and as far
as shows though she-hulk I'm most
excited for alright at least I'm most
excited to find out what it's going to
be because I've wanted a she-hulk show
for a very long time
but I've wanted a very specific thing
out of a she-hulk show so we will I need
to find out whether or not what they're
going to do is going to be what I want
what I've been saying for years I want
to see Hulk show to be if they're not
I'll try and get over it if they are
doing what I want them to do then
it'll be amazing a Lima Colton yeah
pretty much pretty much is you be a
courtroom procedural dealing with
superhero law that is exactly what it
should be
I've never left a morning doctor who
then when I heard the Dalek say would
you care for some tea would you care for
some tea yeah that oh that one's up that
one goes up tomorrow see that like this
is how much shooting I've done I'm Way
ahead or what I've shot but I've still
got a lot of editing to do but yeah
victory of the Daleks goes up tomorrow I
keep forgetting cuz I'm editing further
out from that I want that as a tattoo I
am curious as to what you want as a
tattoo there's some interesting things
going on here I've seen Stubbe ankles
new reviewer reaction to 13 reasons why
um I haven't but only because I haven't
seen the show I still might check it out
cuz I like his stuff even when he's
talking about things I haven't seen um
so I probably will I just haven't gotten
to it yet
speaking of slytherins captain holt from
brooklyn nine-nine is one ambitious
strong leader cunning doesn't get
attached easily but as loyal to the
frenzy has it's arguable that he um
could also be a ravenclaw he's very you
know rule conscious is very by-the-book
um so then part of part of the slither
and thing is a bit more willingness to
bend the rules and grantees softened on
that over the years but I think it's
debatable now he's not as as ravenclaw
as Amy is holy crap but you know final
point don't worry but many speculate the
interview was implying answers to why
chip no struggle to write his own
episodes of a more recent series since
Moffat couldn't help yeah that I don't
want to get into it all because the
minute starting people start speculating
as to why certain writing is or isn't a
certain way not based off direct things
that were said but extrapolating out
from things that were said I don't want
to touch that which is the three
live-action Star Wars shows on Disney
Plus you most excited for oh all right
God are we up to three
because it's the mandalorian the obi-wan
kenobe what's the third one you're gonna
have to fill me in on that
oh did we catch a troll
well slain Carolyn thank you very much
I'm excited for MS Marvel because I'm a
fan of Kamala Khan although I would have
preferred an animated series like
Marvel's answer to System Shock I mean
I'm gonna be very clear to see what they
do because I like come on account a lot
as well what season episode are you on
and Brooklyn nine-nine I don't even know
like I honestly don't at this point if
this was 2009 YouTube I would believe
you would get away with doing a music
video of Doctor Who - Taylor Smith's bad
reputation um well I mean I I have my
one fan music video that I did and I do
have plans for more and I'm not gonna
say more than that cuz like the one that
I have up took forever and these the
ones that I'm working on now are
probably also going to take forever so I
don't I don't want to spill the beans on
that because I don't want people to get
excited for something that I'm not gonna
have done for probably three months
let's see thumbs up or down for victory
of the Daleks I I mean you'll get the
you'll get the review tomorrow but
victory of the Daleks it has some
serious problems but I also feel that it
is largely overrated and is dismissed
out of hand when it's got a lot more
good qualities that I think people give
a credit for but it's got some serious
issues
do you watch Bojack horseman I don't
because I heard it's great but it's very
depressing I'm not in the mood to be
depressed lately I've argue with my
friends over where Jack Sparrow is a
ravenclaw or a Slytherin then there's my
husband who thinks he's a Hufflepuff um
I'm gonna side with your husband I think
yeah I think Jack Sparrow's are huffing
that's that's off the time I had not
putting a ton of thought into it but um
yeah that was actually I was thinking
that even before I read that that was
what your husband thought how awesome do
you think eleven and thirteen would be
together in an episode I think all the
energy and excitement bouncing off each
other would be amazing it would be
interesting it'd be really tricky to
balance those performance energies I
think in terms of writing a scenario
that doesn't just result in chaos a
Ravenclaw's by-the-book people they can
be I always thought they had a tendency
to blow stuff up just to see what
happens yes but usually still within
parameters one of the criticisms for
season 11 that I felt was ridiculous was
that rows ending as the punjab didn't
feel like talk to who episodes they're
close to pure historicals know they
still felt like Doctor Who episodes I
mean Rosa was the closest doctor who's
come to a true pure historical at a long
time I don't think that's a bad thing
doctor who used to do pure historical
that hasn't in a long time and one could
argue that as a show it kind of moved on
from that concept but I don't think
there's anything wrong with doing that
demons of the punjab was one of the best
episode of that season like easily so
the third show is a Kassian and orang
k2s o series set before road one oh like
immediate reaction to that is I don't
care which is annoying cuz I actually
really like rogue one I should probably
like rogue one the most of any of the
Disney produced Star Wars movies to be
honest but I still don't want that
what Hogwarts house would you puts to
bankfull in ooh that see that's an
interesting question because and like
having collaborated with with stuart i
have not like the world's most deep
insight but i have a little bit of
insight into you know his sort of the
character of stu bagful as he presents
himself as sort of him as a writer and i
think they probably get housed slightly
differently I'm not gonna go further
than that I'm just gonna toss that out
there I don't nobody take that as like
him being inauthentic but obviously if
you've seen Stu bagful stuff he works a
lot of narrative threads into it you
know messes with things he's got a very
dark sense of humor that he weaves into
these things sometimes that is you know
kind of reflective of specific creative
thing that he favors not always
reflected into the way that he presents
himself as a persona so that's sort of
what I mean by the difference between
him as a writer versus him as a
presenter Daleks are drunk hufflepuffs
see I I disagree with that only because
Liz had toss out the idea that the Hulk
is a drunk Hufflepuff and now that is my
image of a drunk Hufflepuff so Daleks
know that I can't I can't slot that in
there do you think black mayor has gone
downhill
and do you think it needs an extended
break to get itself together well I mean
it it takes its time between seasons
nothing feels rushed
I thought the latest pipes of episodes
were pretty good um I love striking
vipers I thought that one was great
I thought bandar snacks was a really
fascinating experiment um no I don't
think it's really gone down on hell
Italy but I'd also realized I say that
as someone who discovered black mirror
during season 4 which some people are
already arguing was a worse season than
the first three so you know they take it
with a grain of salt
I suppose if that figures into your
calculations I don't know if you are
Trek fam but a funding video could be
assemble your idea
crew from all previous characters um I'm
a casual Trek fan I grew up a little bit
on next generation but there's no era of
Trek that I have seen everything off
I've seen that the most next generation
but even that I'd like massive swaths of
it I've never seen I've seen all the
theatrically released movies you know um
Star Trek period I've seen all of those
I've seen bits and pieces of the
original series I've seen very little
DSi and I couldn't get into it when it
was airing because I didn't have the
ability to watch it on a weekly basis so
at that point in time I had no interest
in shows with continuing stories because
I was never able to keep up with them
mycotic sporadic episodes of Voyager
here and there I I had a girlfriend in
high school who really dug the heck out
of boys here it seemed okay I only ever
did one episode of enterprise did not
like it at all and never went back I
haven't seen discovery so like I my
knowledge of Trek is super super spotty
if Matt
[Music]
i mood were to meet John Constantine do
you think they would find he do you
think they would find each other to hold
evil within each other and find ways to
fix each other in destructive ways I I
have a feeling that John Constantine and
mad-eye moody meeting each other would
result in something blowing up it would
just be a question of whether it was
done because they were fighting or
because they they agreed that something
was a good idea that really wasn't if
someone were to encounter you on the
street are you most likely to be
presenting masculine-feminine are
somewhere in between you account me
other streets basically gonna be along
the lines of this so I suppose that's a
bit mixed um I don't present you know
just going about my day I don't present
full masculine or feminine very often
anymore I just sort of like that this is
casual for me at this point you know I
would have pegged to bagful for a
ravenclaw but he's got a slytherins
humour winging media seems like a
Gryffindor to me not my doctor youtubers
aren't Dementors I like it better I like
it a lot Matt that was good ah how are
you in heels oh I'm well practiced in
heels
I also know enough not to not to wear
them out if I can get away with it
because heels heels can be amazing but
man some of the heels I have they I
cannot do them for very long I have some
sues I have I have four and a half inch
heels that I used when I did my my
poison ivy for less number I did not
even realize how how high the heel
wasn't that when I bought them because
they were an online purchase that was
that I was something but identity
September's bisexual Awareness Month oh
dang I should have known that I didn't
that is awesome
very cool shout out to Liz
my partner some other people here have
answered but can you do the Vulcan
salute yeah either hand a building off
of someone else's question if if there
will be another season of Sherlock what
direction do you think it should be
taken in that last series of Sherlock
that last episode especially was such a
mess I kind of don't want more so you
know for me to do for me to even
contemplate what direction what I wanted
to be taken in the answer is just kind
of leave it alone like it's it just went
so far up its own but by the end I just
I couldn't I just couldn't anymore I
don't think I mean if they made more I
probably watch it not a bore be
curiosity and a desperate hope that it
starts to work again but man
well Hogwarts house would you put the
character of Stu bankable I think
character of Stu bagful is probably a
ravenclaw I think real stew bag full of
beans a little bit more Slytherin um you
know I'd through what he puts himself
through if nothing else you've talked a
bit about your personal life before but
I'm just curious what you do for a
living other than YouTube um I don't get
into specifics on my job but I mean I
work in an office I work in sales you
know it's not I'm not cold calling or
anything like that you know I manage
accounts and it's a company that
actually makes stuff so you know it's
not like oh I so dreams or I said I just
know I sell physical stuff so um I mean
that's about all there is to say to it
it's it's 40 hours a week
it helps cover the bills because this
and the patreon aren't enough for me to
make my living yet I I do hope I hope
and I pushed should I strive that's not
there yet so
hold down the 40 hours a week are you
how are you planning on watching Doctor
Who and it goes off of Amazon uh I
actually don't know I need to figure
that out
I don't get why the movie Grease has
such a bad rap these days
um I think just because a lot of the
core concepts of Greece have not aged
well I mean I don't think it's that
people are down with the movie I think
people are down with the the fact that
the core idea ultimately comes away
being Hey ladies change yourself for a
man and hey guys you don't have to
change yourself for a woman she'll
change yourself to be with you like
there's a lot of young and there's
single lines and specific things that
are like wait what it's it just it shows
that it's a piece of a time and it's a
time that has passed so it's one of
those things that if you don't have
nostalgia for it and you're coming in
blind for the first time now it's got a
lot of wait what stuff going on sorry
which Doctor Who novel or comic story ah
dang it
Faust it dark who novel Oh comic story
would you like to see get a Big Finish
adaptation I don't know because I'm
ready
I haven't read very much of comics or
any other novels so I have no answer how
many subscribers do you see yourself
having this time next year this time
next year um 50 would be nice my goal
right now is to hit 40 before the year
is over
it's on Netflix don't worry well
Calmette depends where you are what
Netflix carries is not the same in every
territory like Star Trek discoveries on
Netflix everywhere except the u.s. in
the US it's on CBS is streaming whatever
that I don't want and I'm not gonna pay
for so you know have you ever seen his
to bag post Fifty Shades of Grey reviews
he pretends the book is possessed by
teaming and is forcing him to watch the
videos I thought I'd seen all of his
stuff but that's not ringing a bell I'm
gonna have to check that now if I have
it's it's like faded thoughts on the
Little Shop of Horrors um I enjoy I've
seen both the you know productions of
the play and the movie I I like them
both that's a good show I recently saw
what is simultaneously the worst and
best thing I've ever seen sausage party
yeah I'm what little I've seen by I'm it
looked like a very it looked like the
best possible version of what it was
trying to be but what it was trying to
be is something I don't really care to
watch so I haven't seen it today is
sailor Mercury's birthday which one's
mercury tell me color like and then I
can picture it in my head I never
watched Sailor Moon was one of the few
animes that was airing regularly when I
was at the age that I would have seen it
though but no I kind of missed that one
the blue one okay all right any Broadway
shows you want to see I don't know it's
often Broadway these days um you know
since I moved away from New York and
don't have the ability to go and see
this stuff anymore with any ease I
haven't really been paying attention to
what is even going on on Broadway at
this point so I don't really have an
answer do you think you will ever make
it
into the Chicago TARDIS convention
sometime there's a Chicago TARDIS
convention well I'll have to look into
it now hmm
have you watched 'full Alchemist
Brotherhood Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood um I started to and I
stopped because it was reminding me of
all the things that annoy me about the
initial go at first metal alchemist and
I realized I don't want to sit through
these things again even if overall it's
better then the original was so no I did
not keep watching it am i late
um well yeah you are cuz I'm actually
we're kind of winding down I'm hittin
the time when normally I should be
stopping and I actually got a I got a
pop back over to the discord see if
there's anything you got to pick up
there Oh what type of reviews do you
prefer doing positive reviews or
negative reviews and why um I don't I
don't have an inherent preference
positive or negative anything that I can
be passionate about is fun to review
either because I really love it
or I really hate it that's energizing
the most draining reviews to do are ones
on things that are just that's just
mediocre you know that doesn't get much
emotional reaction out of me I'm like
okay that's a thing that I saw those
reviews of something gets that reaction
out of me can be tough um and usually
like with things like Doctor Who
episodes that are like that I'll usually
still find something that like
intellectually I can pick apart but
anything that gets me worked up in
either direction is fun to do thoughts
on the area51 raid I don't know did that
actually happen thoughts on conjure
points being sent off Twitter didn't
know that it happened either see I'm so
far out of the loop good I hope you
folks realize you're like one of my
primary news sources when people ask me
for my opinions on stuff I'm like oh
that's the thing that happened
apparently
I didn't know till you asked like a
embarrassing amount of stuff ends up
being the case what movie TV show etc
are you most looking forward to this
year if you mean for what's left in the
remainder of the year I don't know there
isn't really a lot left this year that
I'm then excited about I mean um you
know legends of tomorrow is coming back
but I won't see it till next summer when
I hit snap flicks what's your favorite
cuisine you mean as a general broad type
I don't know it's really mood dependent
but going for tie a lot lately though
that's nice where your news source us
yeah been kinda a little bit which movie
are you looking forward to the Joker or
Rambo last Bretta last blood well I
guess it's the Joker by default but only
because I have no plans to see Rambo
last blood not for any massive reason
just I I saw the first one I saw the
fourth one had no interest in seeing the
middle to nothing really stirs me about
last blood do you think Captain Jack and
the second doctor would have been best
mates no I think they they're too
similar they would have driven each
other crazy
coffee's done coffee actually was coffee
and other things as well ah I think I'm
probably gonna wrap it up soon No okay
so guess we're getting a little bit of
details of what happened with contra 4
and she said some stuff that was
considered to be an be unfriendly and it
went from there oh god yeah I just I
just don't have it out of the energy
like I I'm gonna say this and like I
don't want this to come across as me
saying other people shouldn't care
before myself the internal drama of the
lgbtq+ community I find incredibly
exhausting and I have basically
absolutely no interest in it you know I
have an interest in how the mainstream
depicts us but the ways in which we pick
at each other and we tear apart
ourselves whether by ignorant or by
overreaction or just because we will
actually listen to each other in a way
that the mainstream won't listen to us
so we pick at each other just because we
get more of a reaction out of it I don't
know but like I find it incredibly
exhausting and I have so little interest
and that's not to say that I have no
opinion but it is to say that I almost
never dig into it when it comes up
because I just don't have the energy I
find it very draining
[Music]
did you hear about the URIs home
spin-off that you're hearing is news
from me right now it's your opinion
Bailey Jim hmm
I see what you're doing the best doctor
who experience I had was in Cardiff
which had a live TARDIS attraction
people could step inside but I mean I
don't know what that one was like most
respectable Comic Cons have a TARDIS
these days one of my favorite movies of
all times of sideways they'll be turning
15 in a few days kind of movie that
really leaves a movie impact on you I
never gonna run to seeing that one why
do people like the rani she just seems
like cheesy really movie scientists they
can't be bothered to do or work so she
believes people to do it for her see I
don't like the Rani either like there's
a kernel of an interesting concept but I
don't think the character was any good
my little pony has a gay wedding in the
finale cool
I'm out of the target demo for my little
pony well yeah me too so but I like that
it exists and I like that people get as
excited as they do for it but yeah I got
a wrap up folks I got I've got editing
to do I gotta figure out what else I can
get done tonight oh you know with with
Vermont pride having gone on this past
weekend I didn't get anything done over
the weekend so I've got a I've got a
knuckle down
so are you hip with the kids me no no
I'm not so hope everyone has uh has a
great night hope you have a good rest of
the week thank you for turning and
tuning in for this absolutely zero
framework live stream thanks for
watching thanks for supporting thanks
for listening
and remember folks you are beautiful you
are valid you are loved you are the
council and I just ramble on in these
meetings have a good night